look closer because the closer you look
the less you'll see
now you see this movie is a terrifically
fun time Jesse Eisenberg he rocks it
this guy he's like the fastest talking
Jew in the world next events lon he's
cooler than he normally is just the four
horsemen in general are awesome
especially Woody Harrelson Woody
Harrelson you know he's he's great at
playing people who don't give a [ __ ]
about other people isla Fisher didn't
really give her much to do but damn oh
don't she just wanted yeah and dave
Franco you know James Franco's brother
he's like yo bro I could do magic dog yo
my brothers James Franco and that's how
I get work surprisingly he's not a bad
actor the best parts of this movie are
actually when these four are in the same
room together just their great chemistry
bouncing off one another really funny
really delightful to watch I wish I was
part of the group in some way mark
ruffalo he's pretty much the lead at
this movie I'm tired that's my
impression of every mark ruffalo
performance but honestly he's not so
sleeping this one he gets really
emotionally intense a lot of the time
really carries this film well god damn
it Hulk you are awesome a lot of people
get hung up on the fact that oh it's not
about characters and stuff like that who
gives a flying [ __ ] this movie is really
just about the magic heist adventure
that's it this movie does not beat
around the bush it gets straight to the
point ha that's a title of the show it
helps into the game right away and it
just doesn't stop until the whole trick
is finally complete just having a good
time watching this show and plus
dimension to come in he's in the movie
that is all let me get straight to the
point here all I gotta say now you see
me got it right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
[ __ ] watch you go that's cool that
comment box below and tell me what is
your favorite movie about magic is it
Harry Potter or is it the incredible
Burt Wonderstone who knows so many
options and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of now you see me go
ahead and check out my show that I do
with my buddy Jerry called reasons to
see well we'll give you reasons to see
and maybe not to see now you see me and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go ahead and subscribe to my channel
by clicking on this beautiful link right
here that YouTube has been so kind to
provide for us thank you for watching
ladies and gentlemen goodnight or good
morning depending on the time of the day
you're watching this